Fight Derrick Lewis Francis,
which we thought there's gonna be fireworks or Paul Daley Mvp last night.
Not you man.
Fuck you.
How to call Paul Daily.
You know what?
I'm a wrestler now.
Dude was crazy.
It was.
It was,
it was horrible.
It wasn't good.
But it was better than Francis versus Derek.
I don't know.
It was,
there was moments of action.
Yeah,
there was.
There was able to take down.
Oh yeah.
Which is not going to be Peter Kim down.
Yeah,
but it's not as a shit show.
It's not good for MVPs.
Imagine with Tyron Woodley would do to MVP.
Imagine we don't have to worry.
It doesn't have to worry about it.
Cause he didn't know any Mcdonald though.
But a real Fitch,
Fitch.
But,
well John Fitch though,
he's got to be able to grab a hold of them.
The thing about Paul dailies,
he fucking threatens a shit out of you with that power.
He's got the scariest lefthand and the sport best left end sport.
Yeah,
100% he scares the shit out of you with that power.
You got to mind your p's and q's.
But what I like about page is that I've always said that one day we're going to
see a guy who's a point fighter who learns how to do other shit cause those guys
are impossible to hit because their whole thing.
It's lunging in lunging at lunch.
Wonderboy boy,
a little bit,
right?
Wonderboy a little bit,
but he's more of a kickboxing a point fighter.
Phenomenal.
Kickboxer I mean nominal but,
but what will you see from MVP is like one of the best fighters that's ever even
attempted to fight and it doesn't get touched.
He's so good because we get championships monster with real against Raymond
Daniels.
You should see the two of them fight like Raymond Daniels was another one who
was a legit worldclass point fighter and MVPs on defeat him professional boxing.
But the file is,
he fight.
Nobody's what's still the re the first real fight she had was last night against
daily and there was some holes.
There were some holes that were exposed to,
it was way too easy for dealing with Cannon Hill.
That's true.
He's held.
It was only fights way too easy for daily to take him down,
not that daily dozen.
His next fight,
it's going to be tough.
What was Chris?
Yeah,
really tough,
but what's crazy is a daily was talking so much shit on John Fitch.
After John Fish took him down to daily's,
all he does is talk shit about guys wrestling and then he took it down.
I was like,
I literally,
what is happening?
Right.
And I was get frustrated.
I guess.
I was like,
what is happening?
Right?
What's happening right here?
Miles.
Jury's already busted up.
We're not even paying attention.
God.
Well,
you got to talk about fucking Paul Daley.
It was unbelievable.
I didn't realize how big a MVP was.
I didn't know.
He's 63 so tall for this,
for that division and also like uses it.
Here's three bid fish.
His reaches insane.
He does sneaky shit too.
He did it.
It's like these sneaky right hand.
Did he hit him with,
he tried to hit him with a hook kick at one point in time.
He landed that front kick.
Yeah,
he's a beast man.
If he gets his wrestling,
takedown defense on point.
I mean,
he's a phenomenal athlete,
but the thing,
he has a gift though it is a big enough,
but the thing that he did,
he goes to London,
shoot fighters,
great God damn gym.
The thing that he's missing,
you know,
I mean,
is it just the wrestling,
takedown defense just to take down defense?
Like if he could take a page out of style,
book style,
been on down.
I'm not too worried about him fighting grappler.
He's hard to take down.
Very tough take down and you're coming in,
you're going to pay it.
Yeah.
He's so God damn technical.
He might be the most tactical strikers in the sport.
I watched him in glory the other day.
I was,
uh,
working out watching some old glory fights with style.
Ben,
when he fought a Jason Wellness.
His movement,
he's spending class mean wellness is a world champion.